[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory as
you may remember or preferably may have
watched a few weeks back i did a video
on the major differences between the
book and film versions of hermione
granger well some of you requested that
i also take a look at the biggest
differences between ron and harry as
well
so today we'll be discussing the most
noticeable differences between ron
weasley when comparing the novels to the
films what about harry keep an eye out
for a video about the differences
between his character as i'll certainly
be releasing that in the near future
but for now let's begin with ron shall
we ah ron weasley if you know him best
from his character depiction in the
harry potter book series then the ronald
weasley that you know and love is the
courageous quick-witted and loyal best
mate of harry potter he's also the
youngest son and sixth child of molly
and arthur weasley
and while some of that remains true for
ron's character in the films the
majority of what's consistent between
the books and the movies is rather
surface level i mean yes ron is one of
harry's bestest buds in the movies
and yes he remains the sixth son born to
mr and mrs weasley
but other than the superficial details
there are many more character defining
qualities that were either changed
substantially for the films or omitted
completely
in this video i'll be focusing on four
of these major differences between book
and film ron major difference number one
his amount of courage and bravery unlike
those who have only read the harry
potter series i dare say very few fans
of the films would describe ron as
courageous
in fact in the movies ron is quite
frequently portrayed as well the
opposite
for example in novel version of the
prisoner of azkaban there's a scene in
which harry ron and hermione come face
to face with sirius black who they
believe to be an evil murderous wizard
who betrayed harry's parents
of course this turns out to be quite
untrue
but before they uncover this important
detail
ron not only places himself between
harry and perceived danger he does so on
a broken leg declaring that he's willing
to die to protect his best friend
in the movie version however he's the
bloke cowering in the corner
while hermione takes what should have
been ron's place shielding harry from
sirius black
sadly this sort of thing happens
frequently throughout the films where
ron's moments of bravery and loyalty are
turned into displays of him being a
complete coward and someone else
typically hermione is given his lines
and actions
another example is in the philosopher's
stone where book ron remains calm after
the three friends get trapped in the
devil's snare
his level-headedness allows him to give
hermione a good reminder that she's a
witch and can summon the thing she needs
which happens to be fire to cast the
spell to help them escape
since hermione is a little hysterical at
this point lamenting they don't have
anything to start a fire ron is
essential to the three friends escaping
from the snare in the film version
however hermione does it all and ron
just sits there screaming
another memorable example is in the
chamber of secrets where ron is able to
confront his fear of spiders he's scared
of course but he manages to summon the
courage to do what he needs to do
but in the film he's a laughable mess
to me this lack of ron's bravery is such
a flaw in the harry potter movie
franchise for several reasons
for one it makes ron seem a lot less
dynamic as a person and almost
unbelievable as harry's best mate
for another in the books it's pretty
clear that ron's courage is one of his
most admirable qualities and in my
opinion the reason the sorting hat
placed him in gryffindor
without his bravery he actually seems
rather out of place in the films amongst
harry and hermione and within gryffindor
as a whole
major difference number two his level of
intelligence
in addition to novel ron's bravery the
films also seem to drastically reduce
movie ron's intelligence in the books
ron and harry frequently receive similar
grades and are able to perform magic at
a pretty comparable level
it's hermione who's well about the both
of them when it comes to academics and
book learning
in the movies however harry's character
is portrayed as being smarter and more
adept at magic than he is in the books
while ron is showcased as well kind of
an idiot
don't tell me you didn't notice
in the philosopher's stone for example
there are several times in the novel
that ron does something right like take
out the troll in the bathroom
in the movies he requires much help from
the others to even do that
he also somehow manages to hit himself
in the face with a broom during a flying
lesson in the first film
despite having grown up in a wizarding
household which presumably had this
magical item and while i'm on that topic
might i also just say that the movies
also took away almost every instance of
ron being the trio's wizarding world
expert when he got to share his
knowledge of magic with harry and
hermione who had both grown up in mughal
homes
for some reason all of ron's helpful
tips and explanations about magic from
the novels are handed over to hermione
who in the films frequently shares
information about things she reasonably
would have had no understanding
or knowledge of
finally in the books ron is actually a
pretty funny and quick witted character
cracking jokes and providing wonderful
comic relief
and while yes you may find movie ron
funny i'd be willing to guess that you
find him humorous because of all the
stupid things he does or incredibly
silly expressions he makes the fact is
that while he's technically comic relief
in both depictions of his character the
films took away ron's humor and quick
wit
replacing it with an over-exaggerated
goofiness that you could laugh at rather
than with
major difference number three his
relationship with harry for some reason
the movies decided to portray hermione
as being closer to harry than ron
and while all three are close friends in
the books it's incredibly clear that
harry and ron are best mates
sorry hermione this alteration from
books to movies is actually kind of
infuriating there are so many scenes in
the book series in which ron was
showcased as caring the most about harry
but in the movies ron is almost always
swapped out with hermione as mentioned
she's the one who throws herself in
front of harry in the prison of azkaban
rather than ron
she's the one who says dumbledore asked
her and ron not to send harry letters
not ron
she's the one who insists she'll go with
harry to hunt horcruxes as a useless and
uncaring version of ron sits silently in
the background major difference than
before his appearance
the translation of a character from the
page to the screen is a hard one for
filmmakers
as discussed in my video on the
differences between book and film
hermione it's of course near impossible
to cast the perfect representation of a
character from a book that everyone will
be satisfied with
especially with a franchise as well
known and well loved as harry potter
however since this is a video on the
differences between book and movie ron
how could i not mention the differences
in his appearance
so when it comes to how ron looked in
the books he was described as tall long
and lanky with bright red hair and
freckles now i would say that the movie
version of ron portrayed by actor rupert
grint could only be described as two of
those things
tall sort of with bright red hair he was
not particularly long and lanky and he
certainly didn't have freckles it's
interesting because the statures of
james and oliver phelps the twins who
played fred and george weasley are more
along the lines of how i envisioned ron
in the books
and rupert grint actually looks a lot
more like how fred and george are
described in the novels in any case this
would have been hard to predict when
casting young children
i guess the one thing the filmmakers
could have done to make rupert grint
better match the description of ron in
the novels is put freckles on him but
when compared to all the other major
character alterations they made to ron
this hardly seems important
does it and that brings us to the end of
another video what did you think do you
agree did the movie turn ron into a
useless version of the ron depicted in
the books
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time
akiobrain
you